over the years Judith and Stephen have
welcomed 120 foster children into their
home they know how important it is to
try to keep siblings together
now it's hoped more places for brothers
and sisters will open up after the
amount carers can earn from fostering
without paying tax was increased if the
Foster cares have got a bit more money
maybe they can afford a bigger house so
there's more space or you know better
quality of life for the children to just
have somebody your own flesh and blood
with you is fantastic and too often
children are split up because there
aren't enough big placements for them
the change was announced in the recent
budget it increases the amount Foster
carers can earn from ten thousand pounds
to eighteen thousand one hundred and
forty without any tax implications it
means roughly 99 will not end up being
taxed at all on their fostering income
and Foster carers who could previously
only take on two siblings should now be
able to take on three without being
liable to pay tax the national fostering
group welcomes the help it's great that
the government have chosen to do
something to improve Financial
circumstances for foster carers and it
in a time when there's a 9 000 shortfall
of foster carers across the country it's
especially important uh for to for
foster carers that look after sibling
groups so those are the Foster carers
that pre these changes probably would
have ended up having to pay tax
there are Thomas from the fostering
Network thinks increasing the allowance
paid to carers would be more helpful the
reason that we struggle to ensure that
brothers and sisters live together in
foster care is less about the tax relief
that's applied to it because it's
applied per child remember that's
already something that is per child
um this is more about the capacity and
Foster Care as having houses with enough
bedrooms and space to be able to raise
large sibling groups together and to
keep them together nearly three decades
on the Harpers are still fostering they
hope the new tax relief will help keep
brothers and sisters together when
they're facing the enormous upheaval
being placed into care
Emma birchley Sky News